me and my buddy we like to mix drugs a
little bit we've mixed some LSD one
night and some coke and uh some Molly
and some other things that uh I was just
wondering my buddy had a bad trip on it
we went to a club so you mixed what do
you say Molly Coke LSD LSD and some
other drugs well look dude let me tell
you this man uh and you know this I'm
sure uh certainly your heart does and
your central nervous system there aren't
that many more drugs I mean how many are
you throwing any more ingredients man
you [__] running on detergent you
know what I'm saying what are you you
know what I'm saying you all damn you
might as well [__] do the dishes dude
you ain't partying anymore you know what
I'm saying after so many different drugs
you're not you're not doing drugs
anymore dude you're about to [__] get
a job uh you know mopping service
stations dude you're about to get a job
working for um Tide Pods
so I think
[__] I can't even imagine mixing that
many things man but you guys were out
there let's hear more
party Rave and uh it got wild out and I
enjoyed it you know I was pressed
against two fat Mexican chicks rubbing
pain all over myself you know shirtless
and this is in Colder Weather back when
it was cold so you know uh I just wanted
your thoughts on uh mixing drugs like
that and any crazy stories you had
thanks man thank you you bet man Hunter
thank you for calling dude
um yeah mixing drugs I mean when I was
young they used to do trolling tripping
and rolling and that was an easy one you
know
um but then one time I remember you know
I grew up in the bad acid belt so a lot
of badass it would come through and then
next thing you know everybody would
shave their legs you know the next week
men and women you're like well what the
[__] happened it would just shrimp up
your genetics so you know you was kind
of swirling a little bit and everybody
would do something weird after everybody
would shave off their eyebrows you know
or you know I remember one time some bad
acid came through and a couple people's
dad started wearing eye patches after
that and you knew who had done the acid
because you knew you know the next week
everybody's [__] out there just pi
written just freelancing and I remember
one time this girl what was that girl's
name man Christy thick Christie they
called her because she was exactly as
advertised and she had them and you
could find a titty anywhere on her you
know you could [__]
she just felt like about 90 titties you
know in a tight shirt and she she she we
were at a party and we had this group we
used to do some acid with and you know
she took a couple hits of something and
and then she got scared she got locked
in a room you know she wanted to be in
there and we didn't lock her in I don't
think necessarily
you know but uh she stayed in there and
we stayed outside and people would go in
there and pour kind of warm water on her
you know and she you know
was it right was it wrong who knows I
mean everybody in the whole [__]
house was on LSD so it's not like
you know we could have thought we were
making tea we could have thought we were
making soup you know we could have
thought we was making human soup I don't
[__] know but I remember going into a
room high on LSD we're all scared
thinking there's like a bear in there
and it's just thick Christy in there
and the lights are out and she just see
her eyes and because when somebody's on
acid bro
their eyes are running about 45 watts
each so you just see her in the distance
and we'll go over there and just pour a
little bit of warm water out of a
cooking bucket cooking pale you know
just like a macaroni pail and I don't
know if she was drinking it or just
letting it Splash on her back or
whatever but that was something that got
a little bit weird one time we had this
boy named Joseph at a party one time
he's like let's play hide and go seek
and then he started counting and ran off
to hide at the same time and he was on
LSD and never [__] saw that dude
Again part of the problem was he had
taken on both responsibilities of the
game so if everybody anybody who was
thinking oh I'll play hide and go seek
on acid seems like fun but suddenly when
Joseph's counting and running to hide
he's [__] himself who knows what he
counted to maybe a hundred next you know
he gets to a hundred but he's hiding
somewhere
and maybe that's when he starts looking
for himself who knows what happened to
him could have ended up homeless
probably ended up I would guess honestly
dude uh down in Tampa he could be the
mayor now
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one